Je vais te parler d'une balle qui tourne, sauf que ce n'est pas une balle et qu'elle ne tourne pas — aujourd'hui dans Qiskit in the
classroom, on va parler de cette propriété quantique appelée le spin en examinant l'expérience qui en a trouvé les premières preuves.
Bienvenue dans Qiskit in the classroom. Dans cette série, on utilisera Qiskit pour explorer quelques concepts fondamentaux couramment
abordés dans les cours liés à l'informatique quantique. Chaque vidéo sera également accompagnée d'un module interactif
lié dans la description ci-dessous, alors n'hésite pas à y jeter un œil. Aujourd'hui, on parle de l'expérience de Stern-Gerlach de 1922.
C'est l'une des plus célèbres de l'histoire de la théorie quantique, car elle montre de façon si évidente comment le spin quantique
fonctionne. Mais ce n'est pas ce que Stern ou Gerlach voulaient démontrer. L'expérience était conçue pour tester un nouveau modèle quantique
de l'atome appelé le modèle de Bohr, nommé d'après Niels Bohr qui l'avait proposé en 1913. Dans ce modèle, les électrons tournaient autour
du noyau sur des orbitales discrètes, et pouvaient passer d'une orbitale à l'autre en absorbant ou en émettant
des photons. Chaque orbitale avait un moment angulaire quantifié qui était un multiple entier d'une minuscule constante fondamentale
appelée ħ. Dans les années 1910 et au début des années 20, la mécanique quantique était toute nouvelle — si nouvelle
qu'on ne l'appelait même pas encore mécanique quantique. Aussi, tout le monde n'était pas convaincu du modèle de Bohr. Un physicien
nommé Otto Stern le détestait. Il qualifiait ce modèle d'absurdité et allait même jusqu'à menacer de quitter la physique si Bohr avait
raison. Stern était tellement déterminé à prouver que le modèle était faux qu'il trouva un moyen ingénieux de le tester et
recruta Walther Gerlach pour l'aider à concevoir et à réaliser l'expérience. Il s'avère qu'il n'a pas prouvé que Bohr avait tort — il a
finalement prouvé qu'il avait lui-même tort. Leur expérience était si simple et les résultats si frappants qu'elle a pratiquement tranché le
débat : la mécanique quantique régit l'échelle atomique. Ils ne s'en rendaient pas compte à l'époque,
mais l'expérience de Stern et Gerlach a également trouvé des preuves concluantes du spin intrinsèque de l'électron — une
nouvelle propriété fondamentale de la nature, essentielle pour expliquer le magnétisme, la supraconductivité et une grande partie de
la chimie. Aujourd'hui, je vais te montrer comment fonctionne l'expérience de Stern-Gerlach, ce qu'on s'attendrait classiquement à voir
lors de l'expérience, et ce que Stern et Gerlach ont finalement trouvé. Ensuite, je te montrerai comment tu peux réaliser ta propre
expérience de type Stern-Gerlach avec Qiskit et un ordinateur quantique IBM. L'idée de base de l'expérience de Stern-Gerlach
était de trouver un moyen de déterminer si le moment angulaire d'un électron dans un atome était quantifié, comme
Bohr le prédisait, ou non, comme Stern le pensait. Ils ont utilisé le fait que le moment angulaire de l'électron causerait aussi
un petit champ magnétique autour de chaque atome. On peut donc les considérer comme de minuscules aimants
en barre. L'expérience ressemblait à ceci : il y avait un four rempli d'atomes d'argent
et un champ magnétique avec les pôles Nord et Sud
ici. Le champ était plus fort près du haut et plus faible près du bas, ce qui produisait un gradient pointant vers le haut.
Enfin, il y avait un écran. Dans l'expérience, le four chauffait les atomes d'argent jusqu'à ce qu'ils s'évaporent, puis
ils sortaient du four avec l'orientation du petit aimant en barre de chaque atome complètement aléatoire. Ensuite, les atomes
traversaient le champ magnétique. Les atomes étaient poussés vers le haut ou vers le bas avec une force dépendant de la direction du
pôle Nord de chaque atome par rapport au gradient de champ. Puis les atomes frappaient l'écran. Stern et Gerlach pouvaient observer
où les atomes touchaient l'écran pour en apprendre sur le moment angulaire des électrons. Stern s'attendait à ce que les atomes
de l'expérience se comportent comme je les ai décrits jusqu'ici : comme de petits aimants en barre obéissant aux
règles de la physique classique. Classiquement, ces petits aimants atomiques pourraient être orientés dans n'importe quelle direction aléatoire. Donc, en
traversant le champ magnétique, ils pourraient subir toute une gamme de forces différentes les poussant vers le haut ou vers le bas selon ces orientations. Un aimant
pointant dans la même direction que le gradient subirait une grande force vers le haut ; dans la direction opposée, il
subirait une grande force vers le bas. Et s'il était quelque part entre les deux, la force serait plus faible. Si l'atome pointe
perpendiculairement au gradient, alors il ne subirait aucune force et continuerait tout droit. À cause de cette
gamme de forces possibles, les atomes devraient tous frapper l'écran à différentes hauteurs. Le motif qu'ils formeraient
sur l'écran ressemblerait à quelque chose comme ça. Mais ce n'est pas du tout ce que Stern et
Gerlach ont vu. Au contraire, ils ont vu deux groupes complètement distincts d'atomes sur l'écran, sans aucun atome au
centre. Ils n'avaient pas la bonne théorie à l'époque pour expliquer cela, mais on sait maintenant qu'ils ont vu ça parce que
chaque électron possède une certaine quantité de moment angulaire intrinsèque sous forme de spin, qui ne peut prendre que
l'une de deux valeurs. Dans notre image d'aimant en barre, cela signifie qu'il n'y a que deux orientations autorisées pour les aimants atomiques. On appelle
ces deux orientations spin up et spin down. Un qubit dans un ordinateur quantique
ressemble à ce type de système de spin, et certains ordinateurs quantiques utilisent effectivement des qubits fabriqués à partir des états de spin des électrons.
On peut donc réaliser notre propre expérience de Stern-Gerlach avec Qiskit et les qubits d'un ordinateur quantique IBM. Associons
l'état spin up de l'électron à l'état zéro du qubit, et l'état spin down à l'état un
du qubit. Lorsque les particules d'argent sortaient du four, elles avaient des moments magnétiques orientés aléatoirement. On
peut modéliser l'expérience de Stern-Gerlach en créant un circuit quantique simple avec un seul qubit commençant dans l'état zéro.
C'est ce qu'on appelle un diagramme de circuit, où le fil du haut est le qubit et les opérations appliquées au qubit
apparaissent sous forme de boîtes sur le fil. Les boîtes RX et RZ sont des gates quantiques qui
font effectivement tourner l'orientation magnétique de l'atome. On peut choisir des valeurs aléatoires pour Theta et F ici pour faire tourner le
qubit d'une quantité aléatoire. Cela imite le four qui éjecte les atomes avec des orientations de spin aléatoires. La boîte grise est
notre mesure : elle nous indique si le qubit est dans l'état zéro ou un, et envoie cette mesure à un bit classique —
la double ligne étiquetée C. Cette partie est équivalente à mesurer si l'atome est en spin up ou spin down en regardant
à quel endroit il frappe l'écran. On peut utiliser une primitive Qiskit appelée sampler pour exécuter l'expérience plusieurs fois, chacune avec
différentes valeurs aléatoires pour Theta et F. Après 100 échantillons, on obtient un histogramme de mesures qui ressemble à ceci : environ
50 % du temps, le qubit est mesuré à zéro, et 50 % du temps il est dans l'état 1. C'est le même résultat que Stern
et Gerlach ont obtenu : c'est toujours soit spin up soit spin down, mais jamais entre les deux. À ce stade, tu te dis peut-être :
bien sûr qu'on a obtenu deux résultats discrets — on a réalisé l'expérience sur un ordinateur quantique numérique qui ne retourne
que zéro ou un. Et c'est vrai. Mais n'oublie pas que la raison même pour laquelle les ordinateurs quantiques retournent des résultats binaires — en fait,
la raison pour laquelle l'informatique quantique fonctionne du tout — c'est exactement cette quantification du spin que Stern et Gerlach ont découverte en premier.
Les qubits des ordinateurs quantiques IBM ne sont pas basés sur des spins, mais beaucoup d'autres ordinateurs quantiques le sont. Donc réaliser une
expérience de Stern-Gerlach sur un ordinateur quantique nous permet de redécouvrir concrètement la quantification du spin.
Depuis 1922, d'innombrables extensions de l'expérience originale de Stern-Gerlach ont été réalisées. Ces extensions impliquent
d'envoyer le même faisceau d'atomes à travers plusieurs appareils de Stern-Gerlach pour voir comment les spins se comportent dans différents
scénarios. En voici un : envoyons les atomes à travers un appareil pour séparer le faisceau en deux, correspondant à un
faisceau spin up et un faisceau spin down, puis envoyons chacun de ces faisceaux à travers son propre
appareil séparé. Avec Qiskit, le circuit quantique correspondant à cette expérience est similaire au précédent, mais avec deux
mesures au lieu d'une. Ici, on a remplacé les rotations aléatoires qui imitaient l'effet du four par un
gate appelé Hadamard, puisqu'appliquer le Hadamard nous donnera les mêmes probabilités de mesure que le four,
mais c'est bien plus simple à utiliser. On mesure donc une première fois, puis une deuxième fois, et
l'histogramme de mesure résultant pour l'expérience ressemble à ceci, où les chaînes de bits sur l'axe X correspondent aux
résultats des deux mesures. Si le qubit a été mesuré zéro les deux fois, cela correspond à la chaîne de bits 0 0 ; ou si
il a d'abord été mesuré zéro puis un, cela correspond à un zéro, et ainsi de suite. Il semble que si le qubit a été mesuré spin up lors
de la première expérience, il sera spin up lors de la seconde. Pareil pour les atomes spin down. Cela signifie que lors de la première expérience,
on avait une probabilité égale de mesurer up ou down, mais à la deuxième expérience, l'issue était déjà déterminée. Donc les
deux écrans à la fin de chacun des deuxièmes appareils de Stern-Gerlach n'auraient chacun qu'un seul point. Un écran aurait
tous les atomes spin up et un écran aurait tous les atomes spin down. Pour notre prochaine expérience,
partons d'un faisceau d'atomes purement spin up. Dans une vraie expérience physique de Stern-Gerlach, tu pourrais faire ça en les envoyant
à travers un appareil de Stern-Gerlach et en bloquant le faisceau dévié vers le bas. Ainsi, tous les atomes déviés vers le haut sont
spin up. Envoyons maintenant ce faisceau à travers un autre appareil de Stern-Gerlach, mais cette fois faisons pivoter les aimants de 90° de sorte
que le gradient de champ dévie les atomes qui voyagent dans cette direction vers la gauche ou vers la droite. Est-ce qu'on verrait
un seul point, deux points, ou quelque chose de complètement différent ? Pour cette expérience,
on va exécuter le circuit suivant sur Qiskit. On commence dans l'état zéro, puisque notre faisceau d'atomes dans cette expérience est entièrement
spin up. Ensuite, ce gate Hadamard échange les coordonnées X et Z de sorte qu'il a l'effet de faire pivoter
l'appareil de Stern-Gerlach. On mesure maintenant la projection du spin vers la gauche ou la droite plutôt que vers le haut ou le bas. Ici, on obtient
l'histogramme de mesure qui ressemble à ceci. On peut donc voir que le spin selon X ne peut aussi prendre que deux valeurs,
qu'on peut appeler spin left et spin right. Cette expérience montre donc que si tu mesures la projection X d'un spin
qui a précédemment été mesuré spin up selon Z, il sera spin left ou spin right avec une probabilité égale. Comparons
une dernière fois à l'expectative classique, juste pour vraiment souligner la différence. Classiquement, rappelle-toi que
si le petit aimant en barre atomique pointait perpendiculairement au gradient du champ magnétique de l'appareil,
la force sur cet atome devrait être nulle — il ne devrait pas être dévié vers le haut ou vers le bas. Dans ce cas, on ne verrait qu'un seul point au
milieu de l'écran. Au lieu de cela, on voit deux points. Donc la moitié des atomes ont un spin left et l'autre moitié un spin right, même
s'ils avaient précédemment été mesurés up. Donc d'un point de vue mécano-quantique, bien qu'il soit tentant d'assimiler
spin up à un vecteur pointant vers le haut et spin down à un vecteur pointant vers le bas, ce n'est pas aussi simple que ça, comme on peut le voir
dans la dernière expérience. Pour vraiment comprendre ce qui se passe ici, il faudra approfondir les sujets de la
superposition quantique et de la mesure, ce qui fera l'objet d'une autre vidéo. Tout comme on se retrouve avec davantage de
questions sur le fonctionnement exact de la mécanique quantique, Stern et Gerlach aussi. Leur expérience n'expliquait pas
tout, mais elle a grandement contribué à établir la mécanique quantique comme indispensable à la compréhension du monde naturel.
C'était l'une des expériences fondatrices les plus importantes de la mécanique quantique, qui a à la fois prouvé la quantification
du moment et fourni des preuves d'une nouvelle propriété fondamentale de la nature appelée spin. Pour vraiment saisir et
comprendre les règles du monde quantique, des physiciens comme Stern et Gerlach ont dû retrousser leurs manches pour concevoir
des expériences, faire des prédictions, et parfois avoir tort. Il n'y a vraiment pas de remplacement pour l'expérimentation directe.
Alors si tu veux tenter de réaliser de vraies expériences quantiques, rends-toi au module Stern-Gerlach
lié dans la description. Merci d'avoir regardé et à la prochaine !